so the story about the fish tank cleaner
all a lot of us looked at it we said I
don't I don't think president drums
responsible for this guy's death I'm a
little skeptical that this death was an
accident to begin with so now a homicide
unit is investigating the death of this
man this is the Mesa City Police
Department's Homicide Division
investigating the death of Gary Linnaeus
who is the the Arizona man whose wife
gave him a coca-cola or some kind of
soft drink mixed with the fish tank
cleaner that she said she did to save
him from the coronavirus a detective
handling the case confirmed the
Washington free beacon that all of this
is happening after speaking with
Linnaeus his wife Wanda you know there
was a story that came out after the
death which said that the Arizona man
who died from drinking fish tank cleaner
was known as a very intelligent man and
a lot of people on the internet they
said I obviously wasn't that intelligent
if he's drinking fish tank cleaner but
actually the point of that headline the
point of that story was some doesn't sit
right I think he was a mechanical
engineer and his pretty sharp guy
apparently there was a troubled marriage
the wife was apparently vicious to him
in public according to multiple reports
so now this story which was originally
posed as Trump's loose mouth is causing
people to die all around the country
because his irresponsible words he's got
blood on his hands now the story is a
woman possibly murdered her husband and
then blamed Trump for it just like the
mainstream media blame Trump for every
single thing